[Music]
welcome to wolf and Chief's clothing in
this episode The Serpent's whisper we
expose the occult origins of the modern
practice of martial arts and
self-defense with more than 24 years of
active training and experience Eric
Wilson is here to share his testimony
welcome brother Eric it's good to be
here thank you blessings absolutely
let's get started with your faith
upbringing wow um I was raised in a 7th
Day Adventist Christian home uh when I
was 12 years old
the enemy got into our home I don't know
exactly how but my father and my mother
went through a divorce and I know a lot
of people know what that's
like when that happened I was 12 my
little brother was five M and it left
this huge gap because when a father is
not in the home that's what a boy's role
model is so not only did I feel afraid
uh because I did not have a father there
to to teach me what it was like to be a
man how to be confident how to trust in
God I began looking for
somebody to fill that role and one of
the things that I found when I was
watching on television a demonstration
by a martial artist everyone that I ever
saw in martial arts had no fear they
they appeared Invincible like they
weren't afraid of of an enemy they
weren't afraid of their circumstances
they they felt like they had control in
their lives and at 12 years old I had no
control I had no control over anything
that was happening with my parents with
me um and then when I started as a
teenager into High School in public high
school there were lots of guys there
that were trying to prove themselves and
bullies and you know jocks whatever and
I was just a skinny nobody and that made
me feel even more insecure so what
actually Drew you into the martial arts
the power and the control I wanted I
wanted to be able to learn to where I
could walk around and not be afraid not
to feel um helpless in the face of
circumstances so that's what opened the
door that's what really pulled me so
from my understanding the teaching and
the principles in martial arts is that
you're not supposed to use it to defend
yourself at least that's what they say
is the gentleman's rule is that is I
mean I'm kind of hearing something
different okay well there's two types of
commcial art schools in the United
States and across the world you have
commercial schools which usually you'll
find in the mall or in a shopping plaza
and they've got lots of advertisement
big money and then you've got
traditional schools which often charge
little or nothing for
training in the commercial schools they
know because of insurance they cannot
allow very hard contact that's why they
wear all this gear protective gear and
the the contact is is really limited so
which of the two programs did you end up
going to I went into a traditional
school so let's talk about Traditional
School setting what did you find uh
there that was so attractive for you in
the Traditional
School real martial
arts in the commercial they tell you
you're not going to ever use this so
what's the point in training in it if
you're not going to use it why you know
why would you learn to punch if you're
not never going to do that that MH in
the traditional schools they tell you
you want to be more powerful than your
opponent and if you have more power you
can then inflict less damage you can
choose how much damage you want to do
whereas if you don't know anything then
you're just you're forced to do whatever
you can so in the Traditional School
what really caught my attention and kept
me in those type of schools was not only
the physical training mhm but also the
philosophy behind the physical training
in a commercial School the philosophy is
there but it's kept more hidden because
normally when a parent takes a child to
a a karate studio or a Taekwondo plus
they don't want to hear that you're
going to be teaching their children
Buddhism or Daoism okay yeah but that's
what's taught even though it's hidden
behind the background after you reach a
higher level like you see brown belt or
black belt level it is full-blown in the
traditional schools it's that way the
whole time so from the the moment so
when your I'm I'm assuming you were with
your mom when your mom took you would
she just drop you and walk away or well
when I started I was actually 14 years
old and my mom was very much against me
going to the martial arts we went and
looked at a school and she said she just
felt uncomfortable she said I don't know
what it is but I don't feel this is of
God and I didn't want to hear that um I
really wasn't interested in God at that
point in my life life cuz I thought you
know you abandon my family you know if
you couldn't save me from that what else
are you going to do so you decided to
take it upon yourself to fill the void
to become potent and to not be picked on
anymore I found I found a an older young
man at my high school and he went to a
school that was supposed to be Christian
he actually said that he said it's a
dollar a night they teach a Bible verse
every night you'll love it and I went
the first night and it it was the way he
said I came home and told my mom and I
spent the next 20 years as part of that
school okay so when you go into because
there's plenty of these in my
neighborhood and when I kind of peer in
as I'm walking past what I often see is
that children have to remove their shoes
before they go in yes it kind of reminds
me of Moses you know when he was on
Mount Si is is there any relevance to
that in a traditional school and in most
commercial schools the instructors will
tell you you've got to take your shoes
off because we've got this expensive
flooring or there's an expensive mat we
don't want the shoes messing it up but
that's not the truth that's what what is
the actual truth let me let me show you
a quote that will explain this this is a
quote from duke turel he's an instructor
and a friend with of Chuck Norris he
said I don't think people really know
why they're taking their shoes off other
than they're told to do so most
instructors I've asked played it safe
and said it's the TR tradition just
don't ask what tradition because then
you'll be back right where you started
the way I present my answer he says when
the student asks why do we take off our
shoes is a longer version of this he
says the student removes his shoes to
yield to the instructor's right to lead
the instructor removes his shoes because
he too yields to a higher power do they
tell you what this higher power is no
no
um when Moses came to Mount Horeb and
God was there and he saw the burning
bush the Lord told Moses the very first
thing he said take off your shoes you're
standing on Holy Ground on on our
documentary The Dragon revealed we show
multiple quotes from different martial
arts studios different styles and all of
them say that when you step into a dojo
or a daang as it's called in Chinese
you're standing on Holy Ground you're
standing on sacred ground um it it's
funny because all the martial arts
originated in China at The Shaolin
Temple it's called a temple it's not
called a gym it's not called a workout
place it's called a temple it's a
Buddhist temple so are these temples
then replicated regardless of whether
they're commercial or traditional yes
like even even in a commercial martial
arts studio when you go into one they
have what's called the showman which is
if it's a a Japanese uh Studio yeah
that's the front of the school at the
front of the school there will always be
a picture of the founder and when all
the students bow to their instructor the
Founder's picture is behind him he's the
one that's empowering him what that
actually looks like is is when a person
makes black belt or fifth degree or
sixth degree which is considered a
master level or 10th degree which is a
Grandmaster the spirit that was in the
grandm Pastor when you make black belt
that Spirit now has legal rights to go
into the black belt or into the the S
okay and then that spirit is passed
through his teaching to all of the
students that are under him so when you
bow to an instructor you are honoring
not only him but whoever's above him and
above him and above him it's like a
pyramid so this reminds me also I always
have to you know throw it back to my
experiences in yoga you know in yoga you
walk into your studio you know you take
off your shoes yes ma'am um and the
other thing that we also do or I used to
do um was to bring our palms to the
center of our heart and we would bow to
one another and we would say namaste
right and you know what that means yes
ma'am the God in Me bows to the god in
you right yes so do they tell you what
God this is that they're bowing to I
mean above the master no well nobody
talks about it okay um normally when
you're when you hit Master Level or a
high disciple level yeah that's when you
start really understanding the spiritual
nature of what you're involved in so is
it because they then pull back the veil
and they start to initiate you in a
different way or it's because by that
time you've been in it so long yeah that
the spirits have already gained access
you have yielded to what the devil says
yeah so often you know God's word says
take your shoes off for me not for
anybody else that's right but when you
take your shoes off for them you're
yielding to voice of the serpent instead
of yielding to the voice of God so every
time somebody yields and does something
that is opposed to God's word that door
into their heart gets cracked open a
little bit more and finally it gets to
the point where the the spirit says I've
got free access I can come in so two
things you say resonate with me from my
experiences in yoga and it's this
Serpent and it's this heart and that's
it's a similar dragon that happens
because they say you know open your
heart and allow the Kundalini Spirit to
rise with within you yes and and they
believe that you know as the serpent tra
travels up the spinal column that you
reach sedati so talk about that for us
um yeah I don't want to go too deep on
on the STI but the somati it's actually
a union with God it's where you actually
the biblical God no it's it's one of the
Hindu gods and it's funny because even
in the Chinese and the Japanese martial
arts many of the Styles will talk about
the Kundalini so the serpent which God
said was supposed to be put under
Christ's feet right through these
practices you're telling the serpent to
come up the spine from the sacrum bone
you know to the crown right well that's
what Satan said I'm going to make my
Throne like God's Throne I'm going to be
like the most high and you shall also be
if you eat this fruit as Gods amen so
you took the bait you ate the fruit and
now they're dangling this black belt in
front front of you and you've been
working for how many years at this point
to achieve it in the style that that was
my primary style which was Chinese kung
fu it took 14 years for me to make it um
we had five people myself included that
had made it in 30 years so it was like
that's very few you didn't pay for it
you paid for it they said with Blood
Sweat and Tears okay so let's talk about
the Blood Sweat and Tears like what are
the exercises that they had you doing
are you learning technique or is it more
about like spirituality no no we we
learned lots of technique but the tech
technique becomes more spiritual the
higher level you go uh you know we would
run sometimes for six miles before class
I mean we would go out and run on a
mountain trail and then come and do
martial arts for four or five hours you
know we did hundreds of push-ups you did
blocking and punching and fighting we
fought every single night so would you
say this is like a movement Med
meditation the way that yoga is mov
meditation yes and they don't tell you
that until after black belt or after
disciple level is there any meditation
that's invol involved in the school that
I began in not until black belt in other
schools there there is like even in
commercial schools you you sit in a
Lotus position and you'll say uh certain
words so a mantra mantras yes um and
you'll hold your fingers and in the
martial arts usually they use the index
finger and the and the thumb um and you
you were taught to breathe in through
the nose out through the mouth to help
get this what they called inner
circulating through the body it's just
so deceptive it is it is but it what was
what was striking to me was that
everything that I was being taught
contradicted what God's word says um so
back to the mantras because I know that
in yoga it's something that you repeat
it's something that you're supposed to
connect with and this is supposed to
open your heart and lead to you know
Enlightenment is it the same practice
for martial arts um not until higher
level okay not until higher level level
how high did you get the highest rank
that I ever was awarded was a fifth
degree and how far is that from like a
black belt well black belt is a first
degree a second degree you know for me
it took you know four 14 years to make
first degree second degree would have
been another couple of years third
degree would have been another 10th
degree or 10th Dawn as it's called is
the highest rank in the Chinese or the
Japanese or okan martial arts and
normally they say that takes 40 to 50
years it's so curious because even you
know we had a a different guest on the
show and he was talking about music and
how you know music had opened up his his
world to occultism along with the
background of having a Freemason as a
grandfather and he also talked about how
in the system of Freemasonry that there
were these you know steps and
initiations and things that were
happening until you know the highest
knowledge was revealed I see a lot of
parallels happening here every type of
Ault it's always based on a pyramid and
you always have the one at the top same
with yoga you know the whole thing is to
become an ascended Master a guru uh it's
incredible and people really just pour
themselves into it and they're deceived
the whole way and uh never once do they
say you know what could I put this same
attention into reading the Bible I know
right I know and do you know what what's
sad for me um one of the things that I
remember when I started in the martial
arts and people ask me this a lot
they're like you know what was it about
the martial arts that made you want to
go I mean you were in church I didn't
see any power in church I mean I saw
Doctrine you know I knew about the state
of the Dead I knew what day the Sabbath
was I knew you know disciples names you
know of Jesus but when I read the
gospels I saw the the sick healed I saw
demons cast out I saw people get victory
over sin I never saw that in church so
you were missing the Vital Information
that that was happening through the Holy
Spirit and that it took a whole in the
same way that you were practicing
martial arts had you been practicing
Christianity aligning aligning yourself
with Jesus the way that he did and
showed the apostles you too could have
had a better and you just said something
the power comes through the spirit right
in the martial arts and in all the cult
that's where the power comes so in the
martial arts you get people to start
taking a step on the wrong path and
after they've gone so far and they keep
opening up the spirit begins to come in
that's the entire goal is to get that
spirit inside another thing that I keep
hearing as I delve into this you know
occult experience that many Christians
or people who were agnostic and come
back into the faith or come into the
faith is that they notice that there's
all almost like an automated uh system
that's happening outside of their
control did you ever have like you know
one person said automated writing where
something was writing for them and
another person said they had the gift of
clairvoyance did that happen for you in
martial arts there were things like that
yes um but it was much later it was
probably the last few years you know
before the Lord Set Me Free from it so
yes I did go through that I remember I
remember probably the last year that I
was in the martial arts I was I was in
the studio in my in my you know school
and all the students had left and the
UPS man was coming in to to drop off a
package and he told me the total and I
pulled out the checkbook and I started
writing the check and I
remember instead of me just being there
and thinking about what I was doing I
remember it felt like I was being pulled
back behind me like I was above me and I
was looking down watching my hand and my
body move and write that check and I was
thinking I'm not telling my hand to do
that my something else is moving my hand
that had never happened before was there
a feeling or anything around you besides
just you recognizing that this was no I
could feel something it was like the the
hair on the back of my neck was standing
up and you could feel a presence in the
room and it scared me because I had
never felt that
before uh this I had a similar
experience where you know without my
wanting in fact I wasn't even practicing
yoga and one night I was laying in my
bed and out of nowhere I started to
levitate but I could see it happening
and I was removed from my body in
essence this this outof body experience
and I'm noticing that more and more
people are wanting to activate this why
do you think that
is people because of our secular society
and people doing away with God the same
thing happened in Russia you know you
cancel Christianity and the masses go on
thinking this is great we've got a
secular society but that there's this
emptiness and when that when that
emptiness can't be filled by money or
fame you start searching for something
spiritual and instead of people turning
to God where the the true spirituality
is they turn to the occult and it's also
easier because the occult does not um
limit your carnal desires where true
spirituality is about the transformation
of of your nature to change who you are
to change how you think about things and
how you think about people well I've
also looked into this from the point of
like uh the Buddhist and the monasteries
and I didn't know that they also
practice martial arts yes and so in a
sense they do deprive themselves and you
know they become Aesthetics and they
hide themselves sequester themselves in
the mountains and they practice very
rigorous forms were you ever initiated
into anything like that um we had the
same techniques the same uh forms the
same practices but no I never went to
China uh to practice I didn't I didn't
need to in martial arts you talked about
energy
uh did you the chi did you ever find
yourself uh you know there was a movie
when I was growing up that uh infatuated
my brother it was called uh I believe it
was the last dragon and it was about a
young Bruce Leroy yes I remember that
and the antagonist was a Shogun was it
shun and whenever he would you know puff
up his chest and and fight an adversary
he would have this glow around him and
be able to defeat you know all sorts of
enemies coming toward him did you ever
have something like that happen yes
the the energy the last Grandmaster that
I trained under I'd been under him for
almost nine years and he told me
something he said Eric he said to the
beginner we tell the beginner that Chi
energy is breath it it's internal
strength it's breath that's why you
breathe in through the nose out through
the mouth same with uh yoga Pana they
tell you yes MH but he told me something
that day he said to a disciple which is
the level that I was at he said we
reveal that Chi is actually spirit and
it's like the alarms were going off in
my head because of my Christian
background it's like it was almost like
I could hear God saying run run and what
I did was I listened to the voice of the
enemy because the devil normally when
the devil talks to a Christian he talks
in our voice so we'll think the thoughts
are our own and we won't go down and
pray so the devil whispered in my ear
and says well it may mean that to him
but it doesn't have to mean that to you
so I kept right on going and I kind of
see that happening in the Christian
Community you know I see a lot of
faithful parents taking their kids and
even themselves you know practicing Judo
or whatever it might be um but it seems
to me that
they've deceived themselves into
believing that they can separate the two
yeah is martial arts you know the
antithesis of Christian philosophy yes
it is the
antithesis what happened is is when you
look in the scripture Jesus actually
said when somebody comes up to you on
the street and they smack you on one
side of the face yield the other side
turn and let them smack The Other Side Y
the martial arts teaches the exact
opposite the martial arts says when
somebody comes up to smack you you block
and you counter you don't just block and
run you block and counter it's
retaliation so it's not defense it's
offense at the same time Jesus said you
know to Moses you know take off your
shoes and the martial arts says
something completely different you know
you take your shoes off in the dojo I
want to read something to you that is uh
another powerful
quote um and this one has to do with
bowing you know we we we were told in
the martial arts that when you bow it's
a sign of respect there's two different
ways to Bow if I bow to you like this
that's a sign of respect if my eyes go
to the floor that's what a student has
to do to a Sensei or a sefue that is a
sign of submission so you guys also bow
when you're competing is that a
different bow the God in Me is
bowing but they don't tell you that
until after black belt level so what did
the Sensei say about this practice of
bowing let me read this to you this is
from a Zen Buddhist teacher he said by
bowing we are giving up ourselves to the
universe which means the
da to give up ourselves means to give up
our dualistic ideas and become one
when you become one with everything that
exists you find the true meaning of
being same rhetoric I got in yoga exact
same thing the devil just reain Brands
it for the culture that it's coming out
of that's right so it sounds like at
this point you know and and through most
of your life you're serving two Gods
what ended up happening the longer I was
in the martial arts the less interested
I became in God because again I saw
power in the martial arts and I didn't
see Power in Christianity and that was
my fault because I wasn't surrendered
martial art says I'll give you power you
know you just come and do what I'm
telling you to do Christ says you've got
to surrender to me when we surrender to
him his life his power becomes ours
right and then we have the ability to do
exceeding abundantly more than any of
the people in the occult can do so I
walked away from Christianity I was just
you know for me it became almost like a
fairy tale now looking back in your life
was there a moment that you can recall
where your deliverance finally came yes
share I was teaching a class one night
it was a late class um probably ran till
11 or 12:00 at night and it was for
advanced students and I remember after
teaching the class I came home that
night and I set my gym bag down in the
kitchen and I reached over to open the
refrigerator to get something to drink
and when I reached and my hand took hold
of the refrigerator handle the hair on
the back of my neck stood stood up again
and I felt a presence it was Heavy I
don't I don't know how to describe it it
was like there it felt like there was
something that was 12 or 14t tall
standing behind me and it was huge and
it was
powerful because I became afraid I had
been doing martial arts fighting bare
knuckle for 24 years plus and had never
had this kind of fear sounds like you
gained the control you were after I felt
like I had felt like you know I wasn't
afraid of fighting I wasn't afraid of
any kind of danger but what I didn't
realize is is the feelings that I had
inside and the thoughts that I were
thinking they were not mine the thoughts
and the feelings that I had were from
that spirit that had been living inside
of me um so do you think that that night
that Spirit finally revealed itself or
was about to I think the Lord in his
Mercy allowed me to see what it was that
was really empowering me so what was
behind the veil this whole time dis guys
as your Sensei or your or your master so
to speak and what I thought I thought
the abilities were mine I can remember
one time where I was I was fighting two
other black belts and these guys were
bare knuckle they were bare knuckle it
was Hardcore it was not uh Point
sparring and I was fighting the two of
them and it felt like I didn't even have
to think about what to do I was blocking
without even seeing the the punches or
the attacks that were coming but after
that was over with you know the first
feeling that I had was wow you know look
at the power look what I finally
achieved and the Lord had to pull that
Veil back and show me Eric this is
what's giving you that ability and I
remember when I when I finally
surrendered and I said okay Lord I was
there in in my kitchen that night and I
I had my hand on the refrigerator door
and this thing is behind me and all that
training for 24 almost 25 years it was
like none of it was going to help me I
was terrified of what I could feel by me
I was so scared I wouldn't even turn to
look because I was afraid what was there
and I was like I don't know what to do
and it was like from my distant past as
a child I remember whosoever calls on
the name of the Lord shall be saved and
I fell on my knees right there in the in
the kitchen on the floor and I just
started crying out Lord Jesus Christ
save me God is just so amazing amen I'm
so just happy for you I'm thrilled that
you're out of that and it just proves
that no matter how far gone you are God
has not forgotten amen so thank you guys
for joining us we have really been
blessed by Brother Eric's revealing
testimony thank you for spending time
with us I pray that you were blessed and
made closer to our Savior Jesus Christ
so that you will never ever be fooled by
a wolf in sheep's clothing this has been
blessings wi see you next next
[Music]
[Applause]
time
[Music]